monsieur maintenant je vous propose de
rencontrer notre invité cet invité c'est
jean pierre léaud du trésor et
d'accueillir dans notre émission jean
pierre léaud je dois dire d'ailleurs que
la saison 72 73 est une belle saison
pour vous puisqu'il a commencé avec le
le dernier tango qui est un grand succès
que vous interprétiez éco festival de
cannes vous étiez l'interprète du film
de truffaut présenté hors compétition la
nuit américaine et le film de jean
eustache la maman et la [ __ ] qui a eu
un prix et le prix de la critique en
plus je pense que vous devez être
content céderait agréable oui ce bien
c'est surtout bien de revenir à cannes
naturellement quatorze ans après avec
avec deux films pareils ça lui revenir
avec un premier film le film de jean
eustache qui est un film très important
et puis de devenir avec la nuit
américaine revenir avec françois qui à
mon avis est son chef-d'oeuvre est un
film comment dire qui a le temps de
baisers volés comme ça où il ya beaucoup
de personnages qui est un film
d'aventuré d'amour que j'aime moi
vraiment énormément alors j'étais
j'étais très ému de revenir avec ses
deux fils moi bien sûr car vous étiez
venu la première fois à cannes avec les
400 avec les 400 coups à l'époque quel
âge aviez-vous j'avais 14 ans vous êtes
fils de comédien et vous connaissiez
déjà le milieu cinématographique avant
de tourner avec truffaut banuls parce
que j'étais au collège je me souviens
que j'ai envoyé une une lettre avant
soit parce que j'avais envie d'être
acteurs enfin enfin et il me fait passer
des essais et il m'a choisi pour son
film et quels sentiments vous aviez à ce
moment là parce qu'on n'a pas eu
l'occasion de vous interviewez car votre
émission a beau être anciennes elles
n'existaient pas il ya 14 ans quel
sentiment vous aviez vous avez le
sentiment d'être un acteur ou de jouer
une aventure comme un enfant que c'était
c'était particulier moi j'ai revu les
jets revue surtout les essais que m'a
fait passer françois truffaut et en
effet il y avait c'était c'était un tout
petit enfance à l'enfant de
13 ans qui étaient là et franchement
poser des questions et je répondais et
quand j'ai revu ses essais plus tard
bien sûr je me suis aperçu que cet
enfant ce rendez compte que c'étaient là
des moments les plus importants de sa
vie qu'il était en train de jouer et
qu'il fallait qu'il ait ce rôle dans ce
film il y avait une espèce de volonté
est très très impressionnant ce que j'ai
vu dans cet essai c'est ce dont il se
souvient le reste le film c'est une
espèce de rêve
d'ailleurs à chaque fois que je tourne
avec françois je suis toujours dans un
état c'est sûr des vacances ou leurs
ailes enfin c'est un état de grâce quoi
dire je dois dire qu'il y a entre
françois truffaut et voue une amitié qui
a qui a permis de faire vivre dans
plusieurs films ce personnage d'antoine
doinel que l'on a connue avec les 400
coups qu'on la retrouvait des folies
avec domicile conjugal avec l'amour à
vingt ans et qu'est ce qu'il va devenir
antoine doinel vous croyez qu'il vient
tout le livre non c'est fini automne
doinel il s'est arrêté avec domicile
conjugal pour une maintenance et des
rôles la différence des rôles d'acteurs
comme alphonse dans la nuit américaine
sont des rôles très différents
parce que ces génies quoi et alors je
pense qu'il doit y avoir dans un
tournage entre françois truffaut vous
avez dit dans une interview à jour
françois truffaut c'est mon père parce
qu'il vous appris beaucoup de choses et
maui m'a appris mon métier d'acteur se
voulait d'abord et puis il m'a appris il
m'a surtout appris l'essentiel c'est à
dire l'amour du cinéma c'est ça qui m'a
pris ma appris à être si françois c'est
mon père disant que langlois c'est mon
grand père oui bien sûr et en effet je
sais à quel point vous êtes aimée par
tous vos camarades dans le milieu
cinématographique et que vous avez eu
l'occasion d'ailleurs
deux d'entre eux prendre des films avec
des amis que vous connaissiez déjà enfin
je pense que vous devez être très simple
vous devez être très sensibles à ce
climat
vous êtes indispensables non oui c'est
un climat d'amitié sera plateau c'est
les gens que je connais sont des gens
justement qui tournait à cette époque
autour de ce qu'étaient les cahiers du
cinéma que c'est ce qui a été un petit
peu ma formation je les ai tous connus
vers 14 heures c'était le premier film
de jean-luc aussi à bout de souffle tout
ça est justement le stage c'est bien
parce que c'est un c'est vraiment un
rouge temps lui aussi de le même sang
qui coule dans ses veines c'était bien
d'être à cannes avec lui bien sûr aussi
c'est un enfant de cinématiques et quels
sont vos projets quels sont les
prochains films blu nous l'occasion de
vous voir eh bien je pense faire un film
avec bernadette lafont que vous
connaissez jean-louis bien sûr et qui
qui elle aussi si l'on peut dire et est
une enfant de cette grande amitié de la
nouvelle vague est un personnage vivant
et passionnant que nous avons eu
l'occasion de le voir ici la semaine
dernière jean pierre léaud mirsa
[Musique]